our traditional greeting as you know is
good morning but there is really really
nothing good about this morning today
we woke up to the news of another mass
shooting in a country
where mass shootings feel almost too
commonplace we cannot get used to this
today's tragedy is this at least eight
people are dead many more are injured
after a gunman opened fire late last
night
at a fedex facility now this one
happened in indianapolis
police say that it appears the killer
also took his own life
so far his motive remains a mystery
charlie demar is from our chicago
station wbbm it's near the scene
charlie it's been an agonizing night and
agonizing is a word for the families of
these fedex workers
not knowing who survived or who may
still be fighting for their life so what
are you hearing now
gail good morning we are at a hotel that
is being used as a reunification center
for families and
as you can imagine it has been extremely
emotional overnight into this morning
as families are showing up to see if
their loved ones are okay just a few
miles from where we are
at the fedex facility investigators are
there they have been there
throughout the night trying to find out
why this happened
they have an active shooter currently at
fedex the late night shooting unfolded
at a fedex facility near the
indianapolis international airport
police say when they arrived they
encountered the shooter who ultimately
took his life
we have located eight people at the
scene
with injuries consistent to gunshot
wounds
those eight were pronounced deceased
here at the scene
at least four other victims were
hospitalized with gunshot wounds
witnesses described a chaotic scene i
saw
a assault rifle of some sort
i saw the clip and he started firing
jeremiah miller was outside the facility
about to start his second shift
when he heard the gunfire i hear six
shots fired at once
you know
he says he took cover then started
warning other employees
my initial thought was don't die
and escape but then when i started
seeing everybody roll up
from midnight shift i felt the need to
help people
i felt the need to warn people multiple
bullets even struck this car in the
parking lot
blowing out its windows after the
shooting facility workers were rushed
into buses
and taken to a nearby hotel to reunite
with anxious loved ones
charisse grice wasn't able to get a hold
of her nephew raymond who was inside
during the shooting
we've been calling this phone texting
them like they said their phones are
locked up they can't have them on them
at work
so we don't know if you're okay or not
the hospitals can tell us nothing
[Music]
now no police officers were injured
investigators are still at the fedex
facility combing through all the
evidence there as they
will be for several hours trying to
determine a motive jeremiah you just
heard from
he says that fedex employees aren't
allowed to bring their cell phones
inside the facility and he worries that
that may have prevented a call to
authorities
from getting there even sooner fedex
says that safety is their top priority
and that they are cooperating with
authorities anthony
charlie demar in indianapolis thank you